With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver. And with Instacart's in-store prices at select stores, you can do more this winter without paying more. So double down on your shortbread production without upping the price. Add more chilies to your chili without the added sting. Go completely ham on candy DMs and celebrate the season of being extra without paying extra. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver.
Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there, everybody.
Bonjour. Why French? That's why I found out today. I don't know. I'm wearing a black and white stripy sweater. And I just feel like if I had a red beret, I'd be very French right now. You would. Well, I couldn't wear my beret and my headphones to podcast.
True. Before we get into this episode, I mean, are you dying to hear a jumping up and down update? Did you do your 50 jumps? Every day. I'm doing them every day. My calves don't hurt anymore. Really? Yeah.
That was just the first couple of days. days. And I'm, I think there's something to this. It's really great. I have a question for you. What? Are you jumping in sneakers or barefoot? How? What? What? Not in sneakers. So here's what I do. I get up in the morning. I shower or get dressed. I mean, I have to put something on the ladies, some form of support. Right. So they don't bounce like crazy. Right. And then I jump. And then I go downstairs and I get my cup of coffee. and I get my morning started. But it's like very first thing and I'm usually, Sam, what is it?
How high are you jumping? Not high. You don't have to jump high. Okay. I'm picturing you doing like basketball style like leaps for, okay. No, imagine like enough for a jump rope to fit under my feet. Okay, perfect. But I'm not bending my knees.
I'm just jumping up. But then I also like I wave my arms because I just like want my arms to be part of the pumping of the jumping. Perfect. What day are you on? How many days? Maybe like 10 now or something? I don't know. I need to look and see when I started. You got to mark that down. This is where my mind goes, because my house is this older house, right? That if our kids jump upstairs in the kitchen, we're like, what was that? Yeah. I mean, it's so loud. So I started a picture of Lee making coffee in the morning and like, ding, ding, ding, ding.
I'm just jumping up. But then I also like I wave my arms because I just like want my arms to be part of the pumping of the jumping. Perfect. What day are you on? How many days? Maybe like 10 now or something? I don't know. I need to look and see when I started. You got to mark that down. This is where my mind goes, because my house is this older house, right? That if our kids jump upstairs in the kitchen, we're like, what was that? Yeah. I mean, I'm so loud. So I started a picture of Lee making coffee in the morning and like, ding, ding, ding, ding.
They didn't mention anything. I had to tell them I was doing the jumping. No one said, mom, what's happening up there every morning now? Well, you probably have better insulation than we have. Maybe. I mean, you could drop a corridor upstairs and we're like, oh, someone drop something. Are you still patting yourself down, Angela? I don't do it every day. I don't know why that's funny to me.
Because it's predictable. The most predictable thing about me is my inconsistency with a new trend. The only thing I've stuck with is tennis. I'm like, I do tennis every week. That's all I got. Well, listen, why don't we jump into this episode today? We are going to break down the super fan of customer survey. Customer survey was season five, episode seven.
It was written by Lester Lewis and directed by Stephen Merchant. We've got a version of Fast Facts for you, friends. It's called, Where Are They Now? That's what it's called. Yes, Fast Fack number one is called Where Are They Now Character Recap. Cassie helped us with this. We thought it might be good. to frame, where are we now in everyone's storyline?
So last episode, the episode prior to customer survey, Michael and Daryl drop Holly off at Nashua. This is after David Wallace caught Michael and Holly kissing at the Crime Aid fundraiser and said they can no longer work together. Yeah, so he transfers Holly. That was such a dick move, David Wallace. I agree. How many people are hooking up in this office over the years?
Seriously. So many. Angela Martin would have been transferred a long time ago. I know. Well, Holly doesn't think that a long-distance relationship is going to work and ends things with Michael. It's very sad. Yeah. Pam is in New York. She is attending art school and now also working at the corporate offices of Dundermifflin.
She and Jim are engaged. Angela Martin is engaged to Andy. and Andy is very excitedly planning their wedding. But Angela is also having a secret affair with Dwight that Phyllis got a glimpse of back in season four finale Goodbye Toby. So there's a lot happening here. Yeah. And finally, Ryan is back working at Dunder Mifflin,
and he's sort of seeing Kelly and his reluctant aloof dating style. So you guys, this episode originally aired on November 6th, 6, 2008, and Jenna thought it would be fun if we did a little thing called, where were we? Yes. Where were we? Our fast fact, too, is called where were we? Where were we as Jenna and Angela? Angela, do you want to tell us where you were? Yeah, I went into my digital clutter, like you know I like to do, and I have emails for you. Okay. That I'm going to share. The first one is, me and you and Jen Salada, writer, director, Jen Salada, had a thread going. We did?
Yeah. The week this episode came out, in fact, Jen emailed us and said, you guys, this is what I was talking about on set. Have you seen this? And it's titled Ninja Cat. What? And I wrote, LOL So Awesome. And you wrote, ha, ha, ha, ha. And I went to the video and it's now unavailable.
Oh, no. It was clearly has, I mean, if titled correctly, is some sort of cat doing ninja moves? I don't know. Ninja moves, okay? But a glimpse into what we talk about on set, by the way. Yes. Also this week, we got an email from Randy Cordray. Oh, I just love even saying his name because I just adore him.
The email is titled, Office Latest Schedule. and he addressed it, Hi, team office, please see the attached schedule. It is now our plan to only shoot the Super Bowl two-parter in December. We will shut down production for Thanksgiving from Monday, November 17th through Friday, December 12th. We're also going to have a table read on Wednesday, December 3rd. Oh. I know.
And then he sent us a whole schedule, which you would have loved. And it said, who was writing what episode and what director they had picked? I would love that. I know. And then lastly, I have one where I sent you a picture of Isabel being super cute. And you sent back a picture of yourself in a Dallas Cowboys jersey in front of wallpaper that you'd put in your bathroom. And the wallpaper was all these different. It looked like bugs, maybe.
Yes. Yes. So in our old house, we wallpapered our bathroom with the page. of this book that was like, it was like illustrations of bugs and insects and snakes and things. But it was really cool looking. Oh, we thought this was like the coolest thing. Well, you look adorable in this picture.
Well, thank you. I was trying to figure out if it was an early selfie or if you like set the phone down. Oh, yeah. Clearly you took it, but it's super cute. Well, there you go. That's what you and I were doing in my digital clutter. We were getting emails from Randy with schedules. We were looking at Ninja Cats and wallpaper and cute babies.
I love your digital clutter. That brought back such great memories. I know, but don't you want to find Ninja Cat now? I do. Yeah. Well, I did a little deep dive, and I found that in November of 2008, I attended a special screening of the movie Milk in New York. Oh.
And I found pictures of it, and I was reminded of how incredibly proud I was of the outfit that I put together for myself. I styled myself for this screening. Oh, I can't wait. What was your big showstopper fashion accessory? Okay. So it was all black. It was black pants, then this black blouse, but the blouse had like a ruffle running down the front of it. Like, it was a button down blouse. And then on each side of the buttons was like a structured kind of ruffle. Like a prom tuxedo? A little, but it was a buttoned down blouse. A little, but Not super big, but like, I mean, cute. And then I had on a black blazer and I had on black patent heels and I had like a black purse.
But I know that sounds boring. Let me tell you my big style moment. I wore a gray patent belt. Oh. That's right. It was all black except the belt. I mean, you are just really on the edge of like crazy, risky fashion trend.
Yeah, I know. Exactly. I also wore some hoop earrings. Oh. Yeah. Sounds like. Yeah. Lee was my date. Apparently, Sean Penn was there.
I mean, he's in all the pictures when I was looking up this event, but I didn't meet him. Oh, well, I would very much like to see her outfit. All right. I'll send you a picture of it. I feel like if I had met Sean Penn, he would have been like, that's a stylish lady. I'm glad she came to my screening. You know? Yeah.
I'm sure that is like how he measures. Yeah. Like people by their style. Seems like it, right? Yeah, he seems that way. He does. I'm kidding. I don't know him at all.
I know. I love that. I mean, one of the things that has been so fun about our rewatch podcast and is just revisiting this time in our life. You know? It's been really, really delightful. And at this point, it's been long enough that. revisiting the fashion of that time in our life is also kind of fun. Okay.
Where are we? Fast fact three. Are you ready for it? Yeah. You don't know it. It's a Dr. Tibido tidbit. I love Dr.
Tibido. All right. Someone shared this with me. I guess he posted this over on our Facebook fan page group. Mm-hmm. Here is what he said. Quote, If you listened to every podcast episode one time up through office food, you have now spent
13 days of your life listening to Office Ladies. That's like listening to Office Ladies all the way through the Siege of the Alamo, or if JFK played the ladies through the entire Cuban Missile Crisis. Oh, Lord. Hopefully your 13 days were much less stressful. Aw. But we have created now even more than 13 days, but 13 full days of content for people. I mean, we are here for you if you're going to drive coast to coast.
Yeah. No kidding. We got you covered. Dr. Tipito, I love all of your stats. Well, why don't we take a break? And we'll come back with our breakdown of the Superfan episode of Customer Survey. There is so much more delicious stuff in the Superfan. I can't wait to chat about it.
The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Racketon. Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With Racketon, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to cook, to electronics for everyone. You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love and cashback is automatically added to your account
and you can choose to get paid via Interact E-Transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases. Just go to rackettin.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Terms and conditions apply. Hey, friends, I'm Sharon McMahon, host of the preamble. Listen, I know you're dealing with a lot, and it's even harder to do it when the world around you feels chaotic.
But I'm here to help. Each week, my expert guests and I slow things down to talk about the stories shaping our world, what's really happening behind the headlines, why it matters, how it all connects. And if you're ready for real understanding and maybe even a little bit of hope, follow and listen to the preamble wherever you get your podcasts. all right we are back and let's talk about a few of the storylines in this episode starting with the cold open where michael is lying about being engaged to holly oh yes michael has everyone gathered around him in his office he's sitting at his desk and in true michael fashion
he asked to lie and say everything is fine and not only that they're engaged lady in the extended version michael really really spends a yarn that's so much longer than the one that is in the original broadcast. He details his huge proposal to Holly. It made me laugh so hard. I want us to hear the whole thing. Come on. How did you propose?
Spill it. Were you wasted? How did I propose? Let me see. Well, I drove her up to Nashua and I had the ring. Big 10-carat diamond. It was beautiful. And I got down on my hands and knees and shooting star.
crossed overhead and it just lit up the diamond like a shooting star and we were in a restaurant and i put the diamond into a cheeseburger and she took a bite started to choke so what do i do ixed PR training, go around, start doing the Heimlich. The ring pops out of her mouth, hits her shrimp cocktail right onto her finger. Million to one shot. All of the Greek people in the restaurant start screaming, who bah! Which means congratulations.
Oh, man. Okay, I just, can we talk about how in his fantasy, he could make this engagement anything he would, wanted. In his fantasy, his fiance chokes on the ring, and he has to save her life. Yeah. Amazing. And there's shrimp cocktail. He's on his hands and knees. There's so many wonderful details. There's so many details. I just loved it. And as Steve, as Michael Scott is delivering this, Steve is so brilliant because he is making it seem like Michael is just making this up on the spot and he's got that kind of look of wonder in his eye as the lie gets bigger and bigger.
But we know that Steve was doing a scripted dialogue. But he's making it seem like Michael's discovering it. It's just brilliant. Steve is brilliant. We all know this. That was a big part of the Michael character that Steve had to play all the time was delivering dialogue like that. Yes, with like this sense of wonder that it's coming out of his mouth.
Well, after that moment, there was. one more really great couplet of dialogue that is new to the super fan. Because right after Michael's speech, Andy gets very excited and he goes, big idea. We should totally do a double wedding. You and Holly, me and Angela. And Michael goes, we would never do that. And if we did, it would be with Jim and Pam. And then Jim goes, and we would never do that. And Michael goes to Andy. So there you go. It was like multiple disses on different levels. Yes. This got me curious about double weddings. Would you ever do a double wedding? Would I ever do a double wedding? Yeah. I wouldn't. No. No. I know. I want the party to be my party. Yeah. I don't want to share my party. I looked into it. I guess only 1% of weddings are double weddings in places like the U.S., the UK, Canada, and Australia. There are other parts of the world where double weddings are more popular. But I ended up on some thread about double weddings, and there were two people who shared
double wedding stories, and I thought I could share them. Okay. I mean, I guess, I mean... I think I was on Quora. Oh, yeah, Quora will get you a random answer. You know, here's the thing. I don't mean to poo-poo double weddings for the 1% that have had them. I just, I guess maybe it saves money, right?
Yep. But you would have to really like the other people and really have the same take. Yes. Well, here's what one person said. They said, quote, I have only ever been to one double wedding. Two sisters whose parents had also been married in a double wedding. And their father was the minister of the church. So the logistics were quite a performance, but it all went perfectly. This person went on to say, first, the dad escorted his eldest daughter down the aisle. Then he went back, escorted his younger one down the aisle. aisle. He didn't bother asking who gives this woman. I think he said something to the effect of I give this woman. Then he went through all the vows with one couple and then he did it again with the second couple. So not only was it a double wedding, but the dad was the minister of the double wedding. I mean, I feel like Michael Scott would be so delighted to be this dad. He could walk both his daughter's down the aisle at the same day and he gets to do all the talking? This is Michael Scott's
dream wedding. I'm just asking myself if I'm the younger sister. Am I annoyed? Am I like just this whole thing? It's like I'm the second bride to walk down the aisle. I'm the second set of vows that get exchanged. Like is everyone done kind of like crying after the first one? Also, what about the bouquet Tos. Everyone's fought it out for the older sister's bouquet. And then you're like, you're like in the back one like, you guys, I have one to throw. So am I my book? Yeah. I don't have any details on that. All right. Here's my next letter. My next Quora. I have been a wedding officiant for 20 years and full time for six. That's literally hundreds of weddings and I've done one double wedding. It was for two sisters. One was marrying a man.
the other was marrying a woman. So the sister who was engaged to the man held off marrying her fiancé until it was legal for her sister to wed her bride. And once marriage equality laws were passed, they decided to both get married in a double wedding.
I was like, I had goosebumps by the end of this. I was like, that is the sweetest thing. Yeah, that is sweet sibling, like, support and love. that is really nice. That's special. I know. All right. That's what I got on double weddings, everybody.
So back to this episode. After the credits, we have the scene where Kelly comes into Michael's office and she's carrying a stack of customer surveys. But first, she tells Michael, hey, you know, I just need you to know. I'm out $100 on the bridesmaid's dress that I bought for this wedding that turned out to be fake. In the broadcast version, she sort of drops that news. and then Michael says, are those the customer surveys? Like, the joke is that he just kind of ignores her.
Yeah. In the superfan version, this conversation was longer. And Michael expands on what it's been like for him since he lost his fake fiancé. I think we should hear it. So I returned my bridesma dress, and it was on sale, so I'm out $100. And I'm out of fiancé. You know what that feels like? it is like
hot sand that you drink and then you go to get a glass of water and it's just more hot sand and then you start thinking why is hot sand coming out of my faucet you want to talk to your fiancé about it but she's gone
that's actually how I feel about my dress I know I love that no matter what Michael says Kelly's going to bring it back to her dress but also So how did she even have time to buy a dress? Didn't he's only had this fake fiancé for like,
didn't it all fall apart all in the same? Oh, yeah. Do you think Kelly had bought this dress and wanted to return it? And this is like she's trying to get Michael to pay for it. It was like not connected. I don't know. Or am I missing something? Like, I feel like didn't he announce he was engaged and then it all fell apart all in the same scene?
It definitely feels like it fell apart in the same day. Yes. Well, we also learn pretty quickly that Jim and Dwight didn't do well on their customer surveys. And Sam, Cassie, Jenna, four minutes and 47 seconds. Clacky balls! Clacky balls, catch. Yeah. Yeah.
I just really miss a clacky ball catch. I still have the clacky balls that Cassie untangled for me in my office. Sam, it was a gift you gave me. I just want you to know. Wait. Didn't somebody else? as clacky balls get tangled and we never untangled them? Didn't that happen?
Are they mine? Are my clacky balls tangled? No, mine were tangled for like almost a year because my friends, my neighbor's toddler, came over and went, like, wait, wait, wait. You guys, please hold. I need to check my clacky balls. Holding. Well, are your clacky balls tangled?
Um, you tell me. Nope. No. It's so frustrating to watch. It's so satisfying. I think it's so satisfying. All right. My clacky balls are fine.
I couldn't wait. I'm sorry, everybody. I didn't want to wait until after we were done podcasting to know. Well, there you have it. Clacky ball catch. I also have another moment in this scene between Jim and Michael that I want to point out. First of all, one of my favorite lines in the whole episode, which is when Jim's like, how'd I do?
And Michael goes, you did poopie. It's like so funny to me that he said the word poopie. I don't know. It makes me laugh every time. But Michael also mashes two words to form a new word. Lady, there's a new Michael word. We did not talk about this in any detail the first time we rewatched it. We sort of lightly mention it, but we don't share it in its full moment.
You know what I mean? Okay. So in this moment, Michael is reading comments that people have said about Jim in his customer's review. And Michael says, let's see what we can find out. Sorry. This line also made me laugh. I'm sorry.
This whole scene got me. Jim's like, can I see what people said? And Michael's like, yeah. And he goes, let's see what we can find out with reading. What? With reading just made me laugh. And then he reads, Jim Halpert is smudge and arrogant. And Jim goes, I think you mean smug.
And Michael goes, arrogant. And Jim goes, come on, Michael. and then Michael says, and there's our smudgness. Smudgness. Yeah. It's smudged and arrogant. I love it. I want to start using smudgness.
All right. I'll do it with you. Okay. Well, this scene extends further in the superfan version, and we see who actually did well on the customer survey. Stanley and Phyllis are high fiving. Andy awkwardly tries to get in on the high five, but their whole desk clop did well. Yeah. This is suspect.
Well, I want to discuss. the scene in the kitchen with Jim and Andy. This is the one where Jim is drinking from Andy's mug. Andy wants coffee and he's annoyed because Jim is using the mug and he asked Jim to swap it out, but Jim refuses. Yeah. I mean, I love it because Andy says, dude, that is my face. Like, it's very clearly his mug.
Yes, and Jim, like, holds the coffee cup up and then Andy makes the face on the mug. Yeah. Well, listen, we talked a lot about these mugs when we first broke down this episode, but we didn't discuss this scene, which I would like to do now, because I want to know, how do we feel about this? Also, we got a fan letter from Vanessa G. who said, not a question, but more of a comment. Jim has no sense of personal boundaries. He drinks out of Andy's cup, which he later does with Daryl's mug and doesn't find it wrong. Remember when they're an athlete and he's drinking out of Daryl's stuff? Yeah, yeah. Okay.
When I rewatch this episode, I was also struck by this. So here are my questions for us. Number one, is Andy being unreasonable asking Jim to switch mugs? Number two, is Jim being a dick? Number three, are you possessive about your coffee mug? And number four, how would you feel if you saw someone drinking from your mug? Begin. I have strong feelings right out of the gate.
Okay. Andy is not being unreasonable. That's his mug with his face on. it and he probably drinks out of it every day. Yes, Jim is a dick. Yes, I'm possessive about my coffee mug. And I would not like someone drinking out of my hummingbird coffee mug. I feel the same. I feel 100% the same. Like how much effort is it for Jim to just transfer his coffee into another mug and give Andy his mug back and say, oh my God, I'm so sorry. Yeah. And look, at home, you know, whatever. I have a bunch of different mugs. Josh might drink out of
one of my mugs. I don't care. You know, they're all. are mugs in our kitchen, right? Exactly. At work, you're working with people who aren't your family. They're your co-workers and you might have brought in your mug from home or maybe it's a mug you got at work, but it's your mug and everyone knows it's your mug. Exactly. I would not be happy if I came into work one day and one of y'all was drinking out of my
pockets mug. I know. I'd say what's going on. I would never do that. Why are you? And I would not drink out of your hummingbird mug. I know. I wouldn't do it.
Mm-mm. Boundaries, people. Boundaries. Well, we also got a letter about these coffee mugs from Roz F, who wrote in to say, there did not appear to be a mug with Michael's face. Was he left off Kelly's guest list? You would think he would be upset about not being invited to her party? Or was that addressed somewhere in the deleted scenes? I thought of this as well when I was re-watching it. Yeah, you feel like for sure you would have seen Michael's face on one of those mugs. I went to the shooting draft, and Roz, here's all that it said I'm going to share with you. In the stage direction, it says Jim stops when he sees something on Stanley's desk. The camera zooms in on a mug of pencils with Stanley's snapshot printed on it. Jim turns to the other desk. The camera whips around and discovers other photo mugs. Kevin has one full of M&Ms.
Angel has one full of paper clips next to a similar mug with a picture of her cat. We pan back to Jim as he heads into the kitchen. Jim opens a cabinet inside amongst the random coffee cups, Jim finds photo mugs of Oscar, Phyllis, and Creed. So no mention of Michael. No mention of Michael. So at the end, when Michael is in that scene with Kelly, I'm surprised he didn't say,
why wasn't I invited to that party? See, now I am willing to suspend belief and believe that he was, and his mug is like in his office. and we just don't see it. Right. Because I don't think he could be nice to Kelly at the end if he was also like if she had not invited him.
Yeah, he would be so wounded. He'd see all those coffee mugs around the office. He would have known. In the way that Jim and Dwight didn't even realize that Kelly had made a gift for her party that a little take-home gift, Michael would have noticed it right away. No, you're right.
Yeah. I agree. So now you guys, Dwight, thinks he's being sabotaged, and he says, these can't be my scores, Jim, for your information, I'm being sabotaged. And I'm going to find that person and punish them. And now he's on the case. He's going to mom detective this. He really is. Do you think we could have solved this as mom detectives? Me and you? Yeah. I don't think I would have picked up on Kelly on the phone, you know, when Dwight's like, I hear something. I don't think I would have heard anything. But she wasn't on the phone.
She was. She was. She was listening in? How did I miss that? Yes. No. He just storms back to her desk, but she wasn't really listening in, was she? Yes. She quickly hangs up the phone when he comes into her nook. I totally missed that. Yeah.
He's talking to the guy, and he literally tells a person he's trying to make a sale to. Shut up. Shut up. Do you hear that? I know. And I thought the guy was like, what? No, I just need paper. And then Dwight immediately runs back to customer service because I think part of their job, like quality assurance is they listen in on calls.
There had to have been blue. For that scene where Rain storms back, because there's absolutely no way that Mindy Kaling, even like the first time he stormed back there, I don't believe she got a single word out of her mouth. No, there's definitely- I mean, that would be really hard for her. There's definitely bloopers. And also, John was really messing with Rain. Remember, he kept pulling his arm back and they were like kind of fighting. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Listen, lady, should we take a break? And then when we come back, we can dive into a little bit of this Jim Pam storyline with the Bluetooth. Oh, yeah, and all the different things they hear from each other's day. And then he mutes some stuff so she doesn't hear. Shady. That's some shady fiancé material right there. Hmm. Yeah.
Jim's doing some shady stuff in this episode with Andy's mug and with the Bluetooth. The muting. Shady Jim. Shady Jim. All right. We'll be back. all right we're back and like we said before this is the episode where jim and pam are on the phone with one another the whole time and so throughout this episode we cut between jim at work at dundermifflin
吉姆在这集里鬼鬼祟祟的，又是拿安迪的马克杯，又是蓝牙静音。鬼祟的吉姆。鬼祟的吉姆。好了，我们一会儿回来。好，我们回来了，正如之前所说，这集里吉姆和潘全程都在通电话，所以这集里我们在吉姆在邓德米夫林的办公室
and pam at work at the corporate offices of dundermifflin and i want to start out by discussing a little of pam's wardrobe okay so there's a whole story here and as i rewatched this i was like Oh, yeah, I see what happened. This wardrobe, we received a note from NBC executives about this episode. And I'll explain why. You might notice I'm wearing a very chunky scarf with a blazer. Okay. And I remember when we were designing Pam's New York corporate look, we wanted it to be different from what she might wear in Scranton,
和潘在邓德米夫林总公司上班之间切换镜头。我想先聊聊潘的衣着，好吗？这里面有个故事，我重看这集的时候心想：“哦，对，我懂怎么回事了。”关于这身衣服，我们收到了NBC高管关于这集的反馈意见。我会解释原因。大家可能会发现我穿着一件非常厚实的围巾，还搭了一件西装外套。好了。我记得我们在设计潘的纽约职场造型时，想让她看起来和在斯克兰顿的穿着有所不同，
but we also wanted there to be some element of her artistic art school vibe. So the idea we came up with was this idea of wearing scarves and blazers. So wait, let me get this straight. New York, Pam, is scarfy? Yes. Okay. She wears a scarf with a blazer. Okay.
但也想保留她身上某种艺术院校的气质。所以我们想出的点子就是戴围巾搭西装外套。等等，我没听错吧，纽约的潘，是个“围巾控”？对。好吧。她用西装外套配围巾。好吧。
She's scarfy blazer. Scarfey blazer. So when this episode went to the network, they came back with a note. They said they felt like there was just way too much fabric up around my face. It's just, it was a real kind of chunky scarf. And unfortunately, I had also worn something very similar in employee transfer. That's when I meet Jim's brothers for the first time, and I'm wearing this scarf in blazer. But that scarf was not as bulky.
她就是“围巾西装风”。围巾西装风。所以当这集送到电视台时，他们给出了反馈意见。他们说觉得我脸周围的布料实在太多了。这真的是一种很大很厚实的围巾。不幸的是，我在《员工调动》里也穿过非常类似的衣服。那是第一次见到吉姆的兄弟们的时候，我当时也穿着这件围巾配西装。但那条围巾没那么厚重。
I also had the same look in business trip, which we had already shot when we got this note about NBC hating the bulky scarves. So anyway, if you watch season five, you're going to see that there's this scarf blazer trend. There's a couple of real bulky scarves. But then as soon as Pam gets back to Dunder Mifflin and frame Toby, it's like no more weird scarf business. It's like, in fact, it's like a cute little top with like short sleeve. Like there's way more skin because they were like, there's all I see is fabric and her face. We need to end to this. I am so curious about who this really bumped at NBC.
我在《商务旅行》里也是这个造型，而我们在收到NBC讨厌厚围巾的反馈时，那集已经拍完了。总之，如果你看第五季，你会发现有这么一阵“围巾西装”潮流。有几条非常厚重的围巾。但一等潘回到邓德米夫林拍《陷害托比》时，就再也没有这种奇怪的围巾造型了。甚至可以说，换成了一件很可爱的短袖小上衣。露出了更多的皮肤，因为他们觉得：“我看到的除了布料就是她的脸，必须得结束这种情况。”我太好奇这到底惹恼了NBC的哪位高层了。
Like, who fired off that email? Who was like, what the hell is happening to Pam in New York? The scarf. Lose the scarf. And then they probably stayed on top of it. They were like, I'm seeing another scarf. Hello, scarf number three, scarf number four. I know.
到底是谁发了那封邮件？是谁在想：纽约的潘到底怎么了？围巾。把围巾拿掉。然后他们可能一直在盯着这事。他们大概心想：我又看到一条围巾了。你好啊，第三条围巾，第四条围巾。我懂的。
And then they were like, I'm sorry, we already shot the episodes. Do you want us to reshoot these scenes without a scarf? And they were like, no, we can't afford that. but for all future episodes, I don't want to see another one of these scarves. I love the idea of someone being really pissed off at NBC about the scarves. They really would micromanage my Pam wardrobe sometimes. I mean, I told you early on, they tried to put me in a pair of pants, and they said, no, she needs to be in a skirt.
然后他们大概在想：不好意思，我们已经拍完那些集了。你是想让我们不戴围巾重拍这些镜头吗？他们大概回答：不行，我们负担不起。但对于以后所有的剧集，我不想再看到这种围巾了。我很喜欢有人在NBC因为围巾气急败坏的画面。他们有时真的会微观管理我的潘的衣着。我是说，我早跟你们说过，他们曾试图让我穿裤子，然后他们说：“不，她得穿裙姆。”
Well, that was an overall note for the ladies, very 1950s of them, because I wanted to wear pants one time, and I also was told they wanted us in skirts. But you eventually did get to wear a lot of pants. Not a lot. Not a lot. Not a lot. Once or twice here or there, maybe for a cold open where we show a jump in time
好吧，那是针对所有女演员的整体意见，非常上世纪50年代作风，因为我有一次想穿裤子，结果也被告知他们希望我们穿裙子。不过你后来确实穿了很多次裤子。不多。不多。不多。偶尔有一两次，可能是为了展示时间跳跃的冷开场，
and then we jump back. But no, very rarely. The only time I was allowed to wear pants is if I was wearing jeans and it was like some episode like where we go to Jim's house for the barbecue or something. Yeah, or like Andy's play. I got to wear jeans.
然后我们又跳回现在。不过没有，非常罕见。我唯一被允许穿裤子的时候是穿牛仔裤，比如去吉姆家吃烧烤那一集之类的。对，或者像安迪的戏剧。我穿上了牛仔裤。那可太让人激动了。
That was very exciting. Yeah. All right. Well, listen, this is also the episode where Jim reveals that he needs his annual bonus so that he can buy his parents home because they want to retire. He has not told this to Pam. So this is why he's so nervous about these customer surveys because they might affect his bonus. And that's why he has to mute.
对。好吧，听着，这也是吉姆透露他需要年度奖金来买下父母的房子，因为他们想退休的那一集。他没有把这件事告诉潘。所以这就是为什么他那么紧张这些客户调查，因为这可能会影响他的奖金。这也是为什么他必须静音。
He has to mute so Pam doesn't overhear everything. Exactly. But definitely Pam is the villain in this relationship. So we want to make sure we remind everybody that Pam is an awful person and Jim is wonderful. Don't come for Pam, people. Now we have this famous, hilarious, amazing butt-licker scene. I could watch this scene every day of my life. I'm not kidding.
他必须静音，这样潘就不会听到一切了。没错。不过毫无疑问，潘才是这段感情里的恶人。所以我们要确保提醒大家，潘是个糟糕的人，而吉姆太棒了。大家别冲着潘来啊。现在我们迎来了这个著名、爆笑且精彩的“拍马屁”场景。我这辈子每天都能看这个场景。我没开玩笑。
I love it that much. It's so damn funny. And just so you all know, it is exactly the same in the broadcast version and the superfan version. it's perfection. They included everything. It's so good. Yeah, they did not mess with it, thankfully, because it is brilliant. I did have a fun catch that I didn't personally clock the first time. You guys might have all clocked this, but I don't know why this whole episode, to me, I was really paying attention to the mangled phrase count. And Jim has his own mangled phrase. It's in this scene, and I want you to hear it.
我太喜欢它了。太好笑了。而且大家要知道，广播版和死忠粉加长版里完全一模一样。简直完美。他们保留了所有的内容。太棒了。对，他们没有乱改，谢天谢地，因为这实在太精彩了。我当时还抓到一个有趣的细节，第一次看的时候我个人没注意到。你们可能都注意到了，但我不知道为什么整集下来，我都在注意那些说错的话的统计。吉姆也有他自己说错的话。就在这个场景里，我想让你们听听。
Here's going to happen. I am going to have to fix you. Manage you to, on a more personal scale, a more micro form of management. Jim, what is that called? Microgermint? Boom. Yes. Microdriment. But listen, I don't think that's a Jim mangled phrase. I think that's Jim speaking Michael.
接下来要发生的是。我得“修理”你。从更个人的尺度上管理你，一种更微观的管理形式。吉姆，那叫什么？微菌管理？轰。对。微创管理。但听着，我不觉得那是吉姆说错的话。我觉得那是吉姆在模仿迈克尔的说话方式。
Well, yes, yes. I should have framed that better. Yes, that is Jim having a little fun with Michael, knowing that Michael will think that's an actual word. Yes. And maybe getting back at him for smudgness. But it did crack me up. And I do have one more other runner I need to talk about, lady. Okay.
好吧，对，对。我刚才应该把语境铺垫得更好一点。对，那是吉姆在拿迈克尔开玩笑，知道迈克尔会以为那是个真正的词。没错。也许是为了报复他之前的自以为是。但确实把我逗笑了。女士，我还有一个支线剧情要聊。好吧。
So finally, we all find out that Dwight was right about him and Jim being sabotaged by Kelly. And in rewatching the superfan version, there is this runner at the end where Jim says, you know, on the Bluetooth to Pam, turns out Dwight was right. And then Pam says, I wonder what else Dwight was right about. And then there are a series of Dwight talking heads. where he is supposedly right about things. It cuts all around the office, out in the parking lot, different days. It's like the documentary crew has compiled these moments over time, and now they're airing them all as a little runner.
所以最后，我们终于发现凯莉陷害他和吉姆的事，德怀特是对的。在重看死忠粉加长版时，最后有这样一个支线：吉姆通过蓝牙对潘说，事实证明德怀特是对的。然后潘说，不知道德怀特还在什么事情上是对的。接着是一系列德怀特的“单口发言”镜头，
I thought it was so funny. So funny. I looked in our candy bag alts for this runner. Lady, the character of Dwight had 32 talking head alts. Wow. 32. Wow. I want to play what made it into the superfan,
里面他自称在某些事情上是对的。镜头在办公室各处、停车场、不同的日子里切换。就像纪录片摄制组把这些时刻随时间推移剪辑在了一起，现在把它们全放出来作为一个小小的支线。我觉得太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我在这条支线的糖果包备选台词里找过。女士，德怀特的角色有32条单口发言备选台词。哇。32条。哇。我想放一放最终进入死忠粉加长版的那些，
and then I'll read a few that didn't make it in. Ready? Okay, great. Here's this runner. It is a fact that major pharmaceuticals do not want you to know that beet juice has medicinal value, both as an aphrodisiac and a laxative. Every article by Christopher J. Kelly of the Scranton Times Tribune
然后我读几条没能入选的。准备好了吗？好的，太棒了。这是那段支线。一个事实是，各大制药公司不想让你知道甜菜汁具有药用价值，既可以作为春药，也可以作为泻药。克里斯托弗·J·凯利（Christopher J. Kelly）在《斯克兰顿纪事报》上发表的每一篇文章，
contains five to seven swear words, hidden amongst the letters of other words. The Scranton Zoning Board has a strong bias against beet farmers. The mayor is in the pocket of Big Lettuce. Battlestar Galactica isn't a documentary. exactly the book all the president's men is about a conspiracy just not the one people think Jesus had a daughter and she was the Mona Lisa according to my sources Scranton mayor Chris Dority checked out patio gardening over nine weeks ago from the
里面都藏着五到七个脏话，隐藏在其他单词的字母之间。斯克兰顿分区委员会对甜菜农有强烈的偏见。市长被大生菜（Big Lettuce）收买了。《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》不是纪录片。真的。书里所有的总统人选都与阴谋有关，只是不是人们想象的那样。根据我的消息来源，耶稣有一个女儿，她就是蒙娜丽莎。斯克兰顿市长克里斯·多里蒂（Chris Dority）在九周前从斯克兰顿公共图书馆借走了
Scranton Public Library no fines no fees no nothing guess who appointed the head librarian what we have come to know is fake crab meat is in fact real crab meat and real crab meat is lobster so much So much, but there were so many more. Here are a few. Dwight would have also said, bananas are upside down. Okay. If ants and wastes ever figure out their differences, it's curtains for the human race. I actually think that's true.
《庭院园艺》，没有罚款，没有费用，什么都没有。猜猜是谁任命了图书馆馆长？我们一直以来所了解的假蟹肉，实际上是真正的蟹肉，而真正的蟹肉其实是龙虾。太多了。太多了，但还有更多。这里有几条。德怀特本来还会说，香蕉是倒着长的。好吧。
Really? Toilet paper? One plie or two ply? How about no ply? What the bathroom tissue syndicate doesn't want you to know is that if you eat properly, you don't need their product at all. Okay, I'm going to tell you something. That's kind of true. What are you talking about? If you eat healthy and you poop, there's nothing, no residue on your butt? I think so. I think it's just you have a clean, what would you call that a clean drop? A clean drop. Every time you have to have a very specific diet. I don't know. What about pee? Come on. Yeah, ladies still need the toilet paper for pee. But, you know, I'm a big believer in the bidet.
如果蚂蚁和黄蜂终于弄清了彼此的分歧，人类的好日子就到头了。我其实觉得这是真的。真的吗？厕纸？单层还是双层？要不干脆不用层？浴室纸业辛迪加不想让你知道的是，如果你饮食得当，你根本就不需要他们的产品。好吧，我要告诉你一件事。这有点道理。你在说什么？如果你饮食健康然后便便，什么都没有，屁股上没有残留物？我觉得是这样。我觉得就是你有一个干净的，你会怎么称呼那个，干净的抛落？干净的抛落。每次你都得有非常特殊的饮食。我不知道。那尿尿呢？拜托。对，女士们上厕所尿尿还是需要厕纸的。但是，你知道的，我是个坚定的卫洗丽（智能马桶盖）信徒。
You know, I moved a wall in my house to make room for a bidet. Yeah. When we renovated our home after we bought it, I moved a whole wall so that I could put a bidet in my bathroom. I love my bidet. When we lived in London, we had a bidet. And when we came home from London, I was like, I can't live without that thing. Yeah.
你知道的，我在家里移了一面墙，好腾出空间装一个卫洗丽。对。当我们买下房子并进行装修时，我移了一整墙，以便在浴室里安装一个卫洗丽。我太爱我的卫洗丽了。我们在伦敦住的时候，家里就有个卫洗丽。当我们从伦敦回家时，我心想：我没有那东西可怎么活啊。对。
I mean, when we went to Singapore, Josh was like, whatever that toilet is we're getting when we get home because it does everything that has a remote control. That's the thing. Now you can get like bidet toilets, but I'm talking, this was like 15 years ago. And like the bidet that I knew of was the one that had to like sit next to your toilet as like its whole own separate thing. But here's what got me into the bidet. Someone gave me this analogy. They were like, if you got poop on your hand, would you just wipe it off with some toilet paper and go about your day? You wouldn't. Right.
我是说，当我们去新加坡时，乔什就说，不管我们回家后换的是什么马桶，它得能干所有事，得有遥控器。就是这样。现在你可以买到那种一体式的卫洗丽马桶，但我说的是，那是大约15年前的事了。我当时知道的卫洗丽是那种必须放在你的马桶旁边、作为一个完全独立的装置存在的东西。但让我入坑卫洗丽的是这个。有人跟我打了个比方。他们说，如果你手上有便便，你会只用一些厕纸擦掉，然后继续过你的一天吗？你不会的。对吧。
You'd wash your hand. Yeah. So don't you want to wash your tush? Yeah. And I thought, yeah, I do. I really do. By the way, this is coming from the person who doesn't always wash her hands after she pees at home. But I do wash my tush.
你会洗手。对。所以难道你不想洗洗你的屁屁吗？对。然后我想，是的，我想。我真的很想。顺便说一句，这话出自一个在家里便便后并不总是洗手的人。但我确实会洗我的屁屁。
Well, growing up, my friend in Indonesia, her parents' bedroom had the bidet that sits next to the toilet, like what you're talking about. That's what I have. This is like the 70s, you know, late 70s, early 80s. And we made it into a Barbie fountain pool. Yes, it also can double as a Barbie swimming pool. All right. Where were we? Yeah, where are we?
嗯，我小时候，我在印度尼西亚的朋友，她父母的卧室里就有那种放在马桶旁边的卫洗丽，就像你刚才说的那种。我家里就是那个。那是70年代的事，你知道的，70年代末，80年代初。我们把它当成了芭比娃娃的喷泉泳池。对，它还可以兼作芭比娃娃的游泳池。好了。我们刚才聊到哪了？对，我们在哪？
Oh, I want to talk about the Pam Alex art school storyline because I have a very important. very fun new tidbit that you know, Angela. Mm-hmm. When we originally broke down this episode, we interviewed Stephen Merchant and we discussed this scene where Alex pulls Pam aside and he tells her, I think you should stay in New York. If you're serious about being an artist, you have to stay in New York. Oh, yeah.
哦，我想聊聊潘和亚历克斯的艺术学校支线剧情，因为我有一个非常重要、非常有趣的全新八卦，你知道的，安吉拉。嗯哼。当我们最初筹备这一集时，我们采访了史蒂芬·莫昌特（Stephen Merchant），我们讨论了这个场景：亚历克斯把潘拉到一边，对她说：“我觉得你应该留在纽约。如果你对当艺术家是认真的，你就必须留在纽约。”哦，对。
You know, Jim is in her ear. He can hear all about it. We also talked about this scene with Rich Summer when he was on the podcast. You might remember it was, yes, Angela? Yeah, I raised my hand. Yes. Just because I want to point out, when Pam talks to Alex and he's, you know, tiptoeing into the flirty land, right? She doesn't mute.
你知道的，吉姆就在她耳边。他能听到这一切。我们还和上播客的里奇·萨默（Rich Summer）讨论过这个场景。你可能还记得，对吧，安吉拉？对，我举手了。对。只是因为我想指出，当潘跟亚历克斯说话，而他（你知道的）开始试探性地进入调情领域时，对吧？她没有静音。
She got nothing to hide. Well, lady, thank you for that. That's right. Yeah. Pam, the awful, horrible person who never supports her husband or believes in him, didn't mute herself. Just something I'd like to get on record. Jenna will never forget. The snarky people who wrote about Pam being like an a-hole.
她没什么好隐讳的。好吧，女士，谢谢你。没错。对。潘，这个从来不支持丈夫或信任他的糟糕、可怕的人，没有把自己静音。这只是我想记录在案的一点。珍娜永远不会忘记。那些写文章说潘像个混蛋的尖酸刻薄的人。
I know, I won't. She's like, I will see you forever. I'm going to talk shit about you as long as I can. You're protecting Pam and her legacy, and I think it's wonderful. Thank you. Well, you guys, you might remember that this was a really difficult scene to film for many reasons. First of all, because it was a spy shot into this glass conference room. And yet Rich and I, we had to be able to hear Jim delivering his Bluetooth lines so that we got the timing right on our end.
我知道，我不会。她就像是：我一辈子都会记住你们。只要我能，我就会一直说你们的坏话。你在维护潘和她的传奇，我觉得这太棒了。谢谢。好吧，伙计们，你们可能还记得，由于种种原因，拍摄这个场景非常艰难。首先，因为这是一个透过玻璃会议室拍摄的“间谍镜头”。然而我和里奇必须能够听到吉姆说他的蓝牙台词，这样我们才能在自己这边把握好时机。
And the only way to do that was to have John hide under the conference room table the whole time. That is so bizarre to me that John Krasinski was under the table while you and Rich did your scene. That is so funny. So that's number one. and then number two, this whole time that Rich was on the show, there was all this back and forth over whether or not Alex was going to make a play for Pam. And it was like, we often shot different versions of scenes because they would kind of decide in editing how flirty they wanted him to be.
唯一的办法就是让约翰全程躲在会议室的桌子底下。约翰·卡拉辛斯基居然在桌子底下，而你和里奇在演戏，这对我来说太诡异了。太搞笑了。所以这是第一点。然后第二点，里奇在剧组的这段时间里，大家一直在争论亚历克斯到底会不会对潘展开追求。就像我们经常拍摄不同版本的场景，因为他们会在剪辑时决定想让他表现得多么暧昧。
So you might remember that there was a different version of this conference room scene that was in the shooting draft. And it was very flirty. And Rich shared with us that he had memorized, the original version. And so when he got to set that day and they handed him this less flirty alternate version, he was having such a hard time
所以你们可能还记得，拍摄初稿里其实有这个会议室场景的不同版本。而且非常暧昧。里奇跟我们分享过，他把最初的版本都背下来了。所以当他那天来到片场，他们递给他这个没那么暧昧的备选版本时，他觉得好难啊，
like getting all that sort of like lovey-dovey, flirty stuff out of his head. He's to this day sort of haunted by this day of shooting. Whenever I talk to him, he's like, oh, if only I could go back. Well, here's what's crazy. Not even knowing that we were going to break this down
要把所有那些卿卿我我、打情骂俏的东西从脑子里赶出去。直到今天，他还有点被拍摄这一天给“阴影”到。每当我跟他说话时，他都会说：“噢，要是我能回到过去就好了。”好吧，最疯狂的是，甚至在我们不知道我们要拆解这集之前，
out of the blue, Rich Summer texts me like two weeks ago and he's like, Jenna, look what I found. It's the original script for that conference room scene. It's the one that I memorized. Oh, wow. Where Alex confesses his love to Pam. So I asked him if he would record it.
里奇·萨默突然在大概两周前给我发短信说：“珍娜，看我找到了什么。那是那个会议室场景的原创剧本。就是我背过的那版。”哦，哇。亚历克斯向潘表白的那版。所以我问他愿不愿意录下来。
And he did. And Angela, you play Jim and I play Pam. I'm very sorry, everyone. Just apologies in advance. My version of Jim is not going to be. What you want, but I just tried to fill in so I could make this moment happen. Lady, I thought you did great. Oh, well, you're my best friend.
他真的录了。安吉拉，你演吉姆，我演潘。非常抱歉，各位。提前道个歉。我的吉姆版本可能不会是你想要的，但我只是尽力填补空白，好让这个时刻发生。女士，我觉得你演得超棒。噢，你真是我最好的朋友。
All right. Well, anyway, here we go. Here is the lost Alex Pam gym conference room scene. Hi, friends. I'm glad we're doing this because it feels a tiny bit like therapy to get to say the lines that I first read that got stuck it so deep in my brain that I could never unsay the sort of intent of them
好吧，不管怎样，我们开始吧。这是失落的亚历克斯、潘、吉姆会议室场景。嗨，朋友们。我很高兴我们能这样做，因为能说出我最初读到、深深卡在脑海里、无论台词怎么改也无法抹去那种意图的台词，感觉有点像在做心理治疗。这说得通吗？好吧。我们开始。
no matter how the lines changed. Did that make sense? Okay. Here we go. Seen 54-55 as originally written. Hey, what are you doing here? Is there a place we could go talk? Who is that?
按原剧本编写的第54-55场。嗨，你在这里干嘛？有什么地方我们可以去聊聊吗？那是谁？
Alex? Sure, Alex. Is everything okay? I think so. I don't know. Ooh, this is juicy. Angle the Bluetooth towards him as he speaks. Hey, Barbara, I'll be right back. Can you watch my phone?
亚历克斯？当然，亚历克斯。一切都好吗？我想是的。我不知道。噢，这太有看头了。在他说话时，把蓝牙对准他。嗨，芭芭拉，我马上回来。你能帮我看一下电话吗？
Where are you right now? Don't go anywhere alone with him. Is this hallway okay? There's no right place to do this. Alex is into you! Okay. Wow. The last thing I want to do is burden you with this.
你现在在哪？千万别独自跟他去任何地方！这条走廊可以吗？做这件事没有正确的地方。亚历克斯对你有意思！好吧。哇。我最不想做的事就是用这个连累你。
Alex, I... Let the man speak. Please, let me just get you. get this out. I won't forgive myself if I don't say this. And I know you've got a boyfriend. Fiance. I am her fiancé, Alex. And a life planned with him in Scranton. And Jim's fine. But you deserve a man who challenges you. And I think we both know he's not that guy. Then who is the guy? Is he the guy? And I don't want to ruin our friendship, but I will risk it for the chance of the future we might have.
亚历克斯，我……让这个人把话说完。求你了，让我把话说完。如果我不把话说出来，我不会原谅自己的。我知道你有男朋友。未婚夫。我是她的未婚夫，亚历克斯。而且在斯克兰顿和他有一个生活的计划。吉姆很好。但你值得拥有一个能挑战你的男人。我想我们都知道他不是那种人。那谁才是那个人？是他吗？我不想毁了我们的友谊，但我愿意为了我们可能拥有的未来去冒这个险。
It's you, Pam, it's always been you. Yeah, well, let's see him propose at a gas station. I see things that nobody else sees the way you are so annoying in the morning. Yep. The way you bite your lip when you draw. What? You draw? I love the way you look at my art. I don't even know what I'm saying.
是你，潘，一直都是你。对啊，让我们看看他在加油站求婚吧。我看到了别人看不到的东西，比如你早上有多烦人。没错。你画画时咬嘴唇的样子。什么？你画画？我喜欢你看我的艺术品时的眼神。我都不知道自己在说什么。
Please tell me he's raising a boombox over his head. Please! Look, just give me a chance. Please. Not for me, but for you. Yes! A million times, yes! Alex, I'm sorry.
求你了，告诉我他没有把音响高高举过头顶。求你了！听着，给我个机会。求你了。不是为了我，而是为了你自己。太棒了！一万次愿意！亚历克斯，我很抱歉。
I love Jim. I hope we can still be friends. Definitely. And thanks for saying all that. I know that took a lot. Yeah. You're such an ass. I know.
我爱吉姆。希望我们还能做朋友。当然。谢谢你说这些。我知道这不容易。对。你真是个混蛋。我知道。
No. Not you. Whatever. And seen. Can you believe he said it's been you? It's always been you. I mean, I also couldn't believe that he said, I see things no one else sees. That's some balls right there.
不。不是你。随便吧。演完了。你能相信他说的是“一直是你”吗？一直都是你。我是说，我也无法相信他说“我看到了别人看不到的东西”。这可真有种。
Like, he's known you for a hot second, but he sees everything. All these other people in your life have never seen in Pam. I know. And then he's like, I hope we can still be friends. I mean, buddy. oh my gosh so many turns you're not going to be friends after this you're not no no and i really want to apologize for no don't apologize my gym is was ridiculous like i mean i think i recorded that like on the go and that is hilarious to me well i'm so glad we changed it to him suggesting that she
就像，他认识你才一会儿，但他看到了所有人从未在潘身上看到的一切。我知道。然后他说：“我希望我们还能做朋友。”我是说，老兄。噢天哪，剧情反转太多了。经历了这个你们不可能再做朋友了，不可能，不可能。我真的想为……不用道歉。我的吉姆太荒谬了——我是说，我觉得我录那段的时候就像在赶路一样，这太搞笑了。好吧，我很庆幸我们把它改成了他建议她不要离开纽约，因为我真的觉得，潘是不可能甩了吉姆去跟亚历克斯在一起的。那太不现实了。但种下关于她是否应该回斯克兰顿的疑虑的种子，却是现实的。是的，在这个场景中唯一对我有意义的疑虑，是关于她对生活中人生追求、职业期望或梦想的质疑，对吧？她从来没有对吉姆产生过质疑。对。那是两码事。对。是的，但如果潘不得不说“嘿，我不想搬回斯克兰顿。我不想跟你分手。但你觉得我们在纽约有未来吗”，这会在他们的关系中产生什么张力呢？我得说，她为什么不呢？他们还没孩子呢。我猜吉姆不会同意的，因为他正试图秘密买下他父母的房子。但是，为什么不调到邓德米夫林的纽约分公司和潘在一起，让她继续追求她的艺术生活呢？我觉得她没那么渴望。
not leave new york because i actually think that create there's no way that pam is going to dump Jim and be with Alex. That just isn't realistic. But it is realistic to like plant this seed of doubt in whether or not she should be going back to Scranton. Yeah, that's the only seed of doubt in this scene that makes sense to me is about her questioning sort of her aspirations in life and her career hopes or sort of dreams, right? She never questions Jim ever. Right. That's separate. Yeah. Yeah, but like what is the tension that would be created in their relationship if Pam had to say, hey, I don't want to move back to Scranton. I don't want to break up with you. But like, do you see a future in New York? And I have to say, why didn't she? Like, they don't have kids yet. I guess Jim's not going to be for that because he's trying to secretly buy his parents' house. But, you know, why not transfer to Dunder Mifflin in New York? York and be with Pam and she gets to continue to pursue her artistic life. I think she didn't want it that bad.
对。我不觉得。我是说，潘不是那种随波逐流的人，尤其是（你知道的）随着她和吉姆的关系发展，她能够与他分享她真的很喜欢住在斯克兰顿。对。她真的很喜欢住在那里。她在那里很开心。我们还发现，我猜这个项目很大一部分是平面设计，
Yeah. I don't. I mean, Pam is not a dormant, you know, especially, you know, as her relationship with Jim grows, she's able to like share with him that she really loves living in Scranton. Yeah. She really likes living there. She's happy there. We also find out that I guess a big part of this program was graphic design.
而她并不喜欢。没错。那并不是她所谓的当艺术家。所以我觉得她觉得我没必要继续追求这个了。对。对。所以她在那里有了一些自我发现。
and she doesn't like it. Right. That's not what she meant by being an artist. And so I think she feels like I don't need to keep pursuing this. Right. Yeah. Yeah. So she had some self-discovery there.
她发现了关于自己的一些事情。她确实发现了。这集里的另一条主线是安吉拉、安迪和德怀特之间的三角恋时刻，因为安迪试图为他们找个完美的结婚地点，
She found out something about herself. She does. The other storyline in this episode is the whole Angela Andy kind of Dwight triangle moment because Andy's trying to find the perfect place for them to get married. but Angela doesn't really want to marry Andy, so she just keeps saying no to everything. And then finally, they settle on Shrewt Farms, which is also kind of foreshadowing for Angela.
但安吉拉其实不想嫁给安迪，所以她对所有的提议都说不。最后，他们选定了施鲁特农场，这也是为安吉拉埋下的伏笔。
She does eventually get married at Shrewt Farms. Yes, and when we discuss this episode with The How We Made Your Mother Guys, we discuss how this scene also shows people getting married in their own graves, and that ends up being a callback. But, lady, we got a letter from Kara T with another callback catch. Kara says, Angela hates the idea of getting married in a tent when Andy proposes this idea, but she and Dwight end up getting married outside in a tent in the finale.
她最终确实是在施鲁特农场结的婚。是的，当我们和《老爸老妈浪漫史》的编剧们讨论这一集时，我们讨论了这一场景如何也展示了人们在自己的坟墓里结婚，而这最终成了一个前后呼应的彩蛋。但是，女士，我们收到了一封来自卡拉·T（Kara T）的信，里面抓到了另一个前后呼应的彩蛋。卡拉说，当安迪提出这个想法时，安吉拉讨厌在帐篷里结婚的想法，但她和德怀特最终在结局时是在户外的帐篷里结婚的。
Was this choice intentional to further drive home the fact that she and Dwight are soulmates and her andy's relationship was never meant to last? That is a great catch, Kara. I don't think it was intentional, but I like it. Yeah. I also loved in this storyline, just Andy, talking about how he got the best tentist. Yes, of all the tentist, he got the best. Oh, poor Andy. Well, before we wrap up this superfan breakdown, I thought we should play a classic Michael Redemption moment.
这个选择是有意为之的吗？为了进一步强化这样一个事实：她和德怀特是灵魂伴侣，而她和安迪的关系注定不会长久？这是个绝佳的发现，卡拉。我觉得这不是刻意安排的，但我很喜欢。对。我也很喜欢这条主线里，安迪谈到他是如何找到最棒的“帐篷师”的。对，在所有的帐篷师里，他找到了最棒的。噢，可怜的安迪。好吧，在我们总结这个死忠粉加长版拆解之前，我想我们应该播放一个经典的迈克尔“自我救赎”高光时刻。
I always love them in our episodes. It's that scene we talked about of when he's bonding with Kelly. and I thought it'd be a really nice way to end this episode. Let's hear it. I have an enormous amount of trouble trying to get people to come to my place. And I hate it. I can't tell you how much leftover guacamole I have ended up eating over the years. I don't even know why I'm making such great quantities.
我一直很喜欢我们剧集里的这些。就是我们谈到的他和凯莉建立感情的那场戏。我觉得作为这集的结尾会是一个非常好的方式。我们来听听看。我有极大的麻烦试图让别人来我的地方。我讨厌这样。我无法告诉你这些年来我最终吃掉了多少剩牛油果酱。我甚至不知道自己为什么要做这么大份量。
Here's what we're going to do. we were going to sit here for a while, make it look good, and maybe you should cry. Can you make yourself crying? No problem. I think you should do that. Amazing. You know that second laugh is Mindy's real laugh. Yes, exactly. It is. I loved hearing it in the episode.
接下来我们要这么做。我们打算在这里坐一会儿，让它看起来不错，也许你应该哭。你能让自己哭出来吗？没问题。我觉得你应该这么做。太棒了。你知道那第二次笑是明迪（Mindy）真正的笑声吗。对，没错。就是。我很高兴在剧里听到它。
Well, everyone, that was our breakdown of this super fan of customer survey. A big thank you to Rich Summer for reading that long-lost scene with us. I really enjoyed revisiting this one. I did too. And you guys, we hope you have a great week. Thank you for listening. And we'll see you next time. Have a good one.
好吧，各位，这就是我们对《客户调查》死忠粉加长版的拆解。非常感谢里奇·萨默和我们一起读了那段失落的场景。我真的很享受重温这一集。我也是。伙计们，我们希望你们有一个棒极了的一周。谢谢你们的收听。我们下期再见。祝你们过得愉快。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Auditius. and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audacy的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾因斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbicoe）。Audacy的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。